[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce premier débat de la saison c'est la
rentrée pour nous mais c'était aussi
celle de plus de 12 millions d'élèves et
900 mille enseignants principale
nouveauté de cette rentrée scolaire la
limitation des classes préparatoires à
12 dans les écoles des réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire c'était une
promesse d' emmanuel macron lors de sa
campagne présidentielle c'est chose
faite
jean michel blanquer air le ministre de
l'éducation nationale n'a pas perdu de
temps pour sa première rentrée en poste
en engageant cette mesure le ministre
veut permettre dit il un taux de
réussite de 100% à la sortie de l'école
primaire dans le département des
yvelines 30 écoles sont concernées
chanteloup les vignes les mureaux
mantes-la-jolie poissy et la commune de
trappes ou quatre écoles ont appliqué ce
nouveau dispositif
alors moins d'élèves plus de réussite en
classe quelle efficacité pour les cp à
12 en plateau pour en débattre bertrand
mesure secrétaire général du snj ppf et
sud dans les yvelines
le syndicat national unitaire des
instituteurs professeurs des écoles et
psg c'est françois andré président de la
fcpe des yvelines la fédération des
conseils de parents d'élèves et valérie
licha professeurs en classe préparatoire
à l'école élémentaire henri wallon à
trappes
bonsoir à tous les sens et bienvenus
nous avions également invité la mairie
de trappes qui n'a pas souhaité
participer au débat je vous propose
quand même d'écouter jeanine marie
première adjointe au maire en charge de
l'éducation au micro de nicolas thierry
lovitz pour nous pour remplir notre
mission nous avions juste sur les trois
réseaux un seul réseau puces c'est celui
de youri gagarine et nous avons pu
dédoubler les cp comme c'était comme
c'était prévu par le ministre ça n'a pas
été compliqué parce que nous avions des
classes disponibles
donc nous avons pris sur ses classes ce
qui fait que les enfants ont une classe
chacun vu les difficultés de nos enfants
est là enseignants aura davantage de
temps pour chacun d'eux valérie chat
selon jeannine mari ça n'a pas été
compliqué de mettre en place ses classes
en plus comment s'est passé votre
rentrée et quel premier constat
faites-vous après vos premiers jours en
classe à 12 élèves céda pas été complice
est compliqué ici quand même ça a été un
petit peu compliqué parce qu'il a fallu
organiser tout le mobilier de l'école
pour refaire trois classes c'est nous
qui avons fait ça et des trois nouvelles
classes de cp puisque ça fait si c'est
payant tout dans l'école balles et trois
nouvelles classes n'ont pas encore leur
mobilier bureaux armoires etc
donc c'est un petit peu pauvre comment
rentrer et a beaucoup beaucoup plus
difficile pour les trois classes mais
bien d'accord maintenant pour ce qui
concerne les élèves
effectivement après quelques jours de
classe on voit tout de suite que c'est
extrêmement bénéfique pour les élèves
voilà ça c'est clair c'est net un enfant
qui est en difficulté on le voit tout de
suite le calme dans la classe l'espace
de la classe qui est organisée d'une
autre manière
il ya aussi cette facilité qu'on a à
faire intervenir les enfants qui étaient
très discrets qu'on ne voyait pas d'un
groupe 24 ou 25
donc ça c'est vrai que pour les élèves
c'est très bien maintenant après c'est
vrai que les conditions
elle a su voilà d'installation ça a été
un petit peu ma clé on va dire voilà
c'est du bac les françois andré la
taille des classes c'est un petit peu la
préoccupation majeure des parents alors
12 ans ces pays ce que ça rassure
alors attendez c'est 12 en cp d'une
toute petite fraction des cp en france
oui donc oui bien sûr c'est un peu
rassuré mais ça serait ça serait plus
rassurant à une échelle plus large donc
bien sûr que tout parent d'élève depuis
qu'ils les parents rêvent pour ses
enfants les enfants des autres des
classes à effectifs allégés et sa part
est frappé au coin du bon sens que de
dire que des apprentissages se passent
mieux dans des classes réduites surtout
réduit de moitié dans mon cas présent
donc bien sûr qui peut être contre une
telle mesure il ya pas de sauf que l'on
parle d'expérimentation scientifique et
là j'ai eu beau chercher j'ai pas trouvé
ce qui prouvait dans les dents dans les
publications l'efficacité de ce
dispositif mais personne ne peut être
contre un allègement des effectifs
on en rêve aussi en collège en 6e et 5e
par exemple donc on espère que c'est le
début d'une excellente tendance dans
l'éducation nationale française c'est à
dire de l'allègement des effectifs dans
les classes mais bertrand mesure le
syndicat que vous représentez plutôt
mitigé non sur sur l'application cergy
repasse sur le leader je rejoins ce que
disent mes collègues l'allègement des
effectifs est une préoccupation
constante que nous avons d'ailleurs
parce que ne serait ce que pour
rejoindre la moyenne des pays de l'osce
et des matières mais là le constat qu'on
peut faire c'est un déplacement la
france la france sur voila sont les
effets sur les effectifs par classe en
primaire mais maintenant le constat
qu'on fait c'est la précipitation
tout s'est mis en place au mois de juin
d'une façon qui fait que la rentrée ne
pouvait pas de toute façon
matériellement se passer dans de bonnes
conditions
le deuxième choix voilà le deuxième
constat c'est celui de des moyens mis à
disposition puisqu'il s'agit il ne
s'agit que de redéploiement cette année
c'est à dire que pour ouvrir ccpa 12
il a fallu redéployer des des moyens
humains qui étaient sur le terrain pour
autre chose
donc ce qui est donné aux as forcément
fera défaut aux autres et puis après je
rejoins un peu ce qui a été dit
cette précipitation manque de réflexion
on est un peu dans une espèce de passage
à l'acte leleu comment dirais-je notre
président d'un public à pense que les cp
alléger ça va être une bonne chose mais
il serait plus besoin d'être travaillés
et je rejoins ce qui a été dit surtout
sur le fait que l'ensemble des élèves de
france et il n'y a pas que des élèves en
difficulté et que en éducation
prioritaire et a fortiori aurait de plus
l'ensemble des élèves pourraient
bénéficier de cet allégement de
l'effectif c'est à une mesure qui a été
décidé un rapidement et enfin il a été
décidé à quelques jours de la rentrée
qui a été mis en place rapidement on en
train d'en parler c'est le manque
maintenant finalement on se pose la
question mais ce qu'il ya suffisamment
d'enseignants ou pas est-ce qu'il y en
aura assez ou pas là je peux vous enfin
vous rassurer ou pas de toute façon ce
matin nous avons
un groupe de travail 1 direction
académique et déjà le constat qui est
fait c'est que des postes de remplaçants
sont vacants et qui ne seront pas
couverts par la direction académique
donc on est déjà en tension nous sommes
le 7 septembre
nous sommes déjà en tension sur sur le
fait que les remplacements vont être une
fois de plus très difficile cette année
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un qualitatif qui
portait sur une toute petite fraction de
la population scolaire
nous ce qu'on souhaite évidemment c'est
que le service public dans son ensemble
bénéficie de cet avancement qualitatif
et que surtout ils aient les moyens
d'assurer ses missions au quotidien
or c'est ce ne sera à mon avis
manifestement pas le cas cette année
remplacement je pense qu'il a raison
maintenant au niveau du travail des ppm
cu d'essai puisque ça a posé beaucoup de
problèmes dans ces zones où les cpa 12
se sont mis en place les pdm qu décès
ont prix dcp à 12 2000 il y avait m qui
qui aide les sceptiques interviennent
sur les cp et ce1 et les ce2 et donc y
aide
le professeur raison d'une matinée par
semaine des choses comme ça et bah ces
personnes là ont une classe à charge à
temps plein et selon les écoles enfin
non dans notre école on va essayer de
faire de manière à ce que on puisse
regrouper deux classes de cp à 12 à un
moment donné pour le sport pour les
chorales pour les choses comme ça et ce
qui fait que ça va libérer une personne
alors où le pdm qu décès ou une autre
enseignant qui va pouvoir intervenir sur
les ce1 ou les ce2 pour aider à ces
moments là alors c'est long à mettre en
chat en place par don et il va falloir
qu'on se mette d'accord avec l'équipe
ça prend du temps il faut que tout le
monde soit d'accord c'est sûr que c'est
à nous de gérer la chose mais je pense
qu'on peut arriver à faire quelque chose
de pas mal est ce que finalement puisque
cette mesure en 2019 ce sont l'ensemble
des classes de cp
de ce1 qui seront concernées selon le
souhait du ministre est ce que
finalement appliqué cette mesure va
permettre de réduire va permettre de
réduire les inégalités scolaires est ce
que c'est parce que j'ai compris j'ai
compris que le dispositif sera étendu
aux rêves qui sont pas là pour le moment
c'est bien lire et plus les touts les cp
de france je suis pas sûr d'avoir lu ça
quelque part dans le programme de
monsieur macron en tout cas est ce que
vous pensez que cette cette mesure peut
permettre un de réduire les inégalités
scolaires est ce que est ce que ça peut
ça peut aider justement les religions
ainsi que le calcul du ministre en soit
il est pas mauvais parce que à moyens
constants
il peut mettre en route quelque chose
rapidement et qui peut être efficace
dans les zones les plus difficiles
donc si on veut si on veut un résultat
tangible
avec peu de moyens puisque il a aimé
mais il faut des doublés il faut 2000 ou
2500 professeurs des écoles de plus si
j'ai bien compris il peut le faire sur
ce qui était déjà voté d'ailleurs par le
budget du gouvernement précédent donc là
c'est pas des postes créés ex nihilo ce
sont déjà des créations prévues à mon
avis par le budget précédent donc à
moyens constants et 10 le meilleur moyen
pour que ce soit visible que les
résultats soient visite c'est de placer
ces postes supplémentaires ces
dédoublements là où il y en a plus
besoin donc je pense qu'il fait pas un
mauvais calcul en disant c'est bien dans
l'est dans l'est dans les zones leur est
plus dans les établissements ray plus
qu'on aura probablement des résultats
visibles
voilà maintenant à l'échelle à l'échelle
de la nation et de fin ce que je lui
souhaite c'est qu'il n'est pas un autre
ministre qui le remplace trois ans plus
tard deux-tiers contrôle z ehkirch ans
d'un dispositif
il va falloir attendre cinq ans à mon
avis pour faire une véritable évaluation
des résultats de cette expérimentation
mais encore une fois je vois je pense
que ça devrait marcher enfin
déjà au niveau du ce2 quand c'est les cp
actuels seront en ce2 on verra déjà au
niveau de la qualité de l'ambiance de
classe la qualité d' autonomie dans le
travail ça se verra déjà en ce2 et
jusque et ses deux sont des classes
chargées enfin normal pourquoi justement
sur l'ambiance de la classe fin certains
enseignants craignent de tomber dans la
monotonie et de perdre un petit peu le
l'énergie en le stimulant enfin deux des
classes à a plusieurs
alors ya c'est sûr il ya un nombre de
rire de dynamisme au début au niveau de
la classe ça c'est sûr mais je pense que
pour ma part c'est à l'enseignant aussi
de deux l'insuffler cc c'est nous qui
devons mettre en place une dynamique et
puis ça se prend petit à petit ça se
fait petit à petit mais c'est sûr qu'au
début sur douze élèves on a moins
d'élèves moteur forcément on a des
élèves qui sont un petit peu plus
perturbateurs mais dans ce cas là c'est
même mieux parce qu'il ya plus publics
pour qu'ils soient regardées pour qu'il
soit et c'est donc je pense que non ça
assez c'est aussi à l'enseignant de
s'adapter je pense qu'il faut aussi
travailler un peu différemment
bertrand mesure un mot de conclusion on
arrive à la fin de cette émission déjà
un mot de conclusion
votre conclusion c'est celui qu'on
défend depuis des années à savoir que
nous souhaiterions que les moyens qui
sont offerts au premier degré dans les
écoles primaires rejoignent les moyennes
des la moyenne des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs c'est à dire des taux
d'encadrement significativement allégé
pour l'ensemble des élèves du primaire
et pas uniquement aurait plus même si
effectivement qualitativement c'est une
démarche intéressante donc une manière
intéressante mais des moyens est en tout
cas une rentrée un petit peu juin
istres a rejoint la fcpe pour dire que
sans pérennité ça n'aurait aucun sens il
y a déjà eu des tbh doublement de cp
mais qui avait duré de mémoire deux ou
trois ans et qui n'avait rien produit et
on peut rêver que ce sera bien entendu
l'année prochaine hausse et un degré
plus et ocp des rep et que ce procès
afin cette mesure sera effective pour
tous les cpc 20 et jusqu'au ce2 henry
peyret plus ça serait déjà formidable ça
représente 15 mille postes
supplémentaires donc voilà on peut rêver
j'espère que ce sera effectivement ce
qui sera en préparation du côté
enseignants on espère vraiment pas prêt
à ce que ccp la travaille pas d'une
certaine manière ça serait bien que ça
se poursuive ancellin de manière sky
d'entre eux deux ils soient prêts quoi
ce sera le mot de la fin on arriva à la
fin de cette émission merci à tous les
trois d'être venu sur ce plateau fin du
set 8 débat qui portait ce soir sur la
mise en place des classes de cp à 12
élèves
l'émission est à revoir sur notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux
bonne soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]